you've got to fly away except I'm the
devil hi everyone my name is Tamara
chambers my mother ruse and this is
Tamara's never seen tonight we watched
Monster Squad so I have had this on my
list since we did the NC monsters 100
yeah just been awhile and I played kind
of the little girl character but I
played like a weird grizzly cowboy you
know yeah which now we know is not
accurate to the film I haven't heard so
many people giving it just the best
praise online so I was really hoping
that it was gonna be fun
I was knowing that it was gonna be dated
but I bright I was hoping like not too
dated and only a few instances I think I
mean definitely a couple of moments we
were like oh I'm excited to talk about
it so let's get a will you snap with me
yeah we don't even have to because it's
the TAM Tober fest intro but we're still
gonna do it let's do it you can do what
we want
towba first I had such a good time with
this week it was it was hilariously 80s
yes oh my gosh likes 80s were showing Oh
quite a bit I thought this story is
absolutely ridiculous oh yeah buddy plot
ho Oh what barely made sense you know
and I really loved it it's one of those
ones that's like what's happening it
doesn't matter who cares regular can
like dine you ate with his eyes right
sure great fine his car can magically
pass through another car only once but
just wants one I love it if he's not
shot with a silver bullet he can like be
completely dismembered and then he just
comes back together cuz it wasn't a
Selena hilarious right that's how
science works I love the opening text
that we get is super serious like Oh a
small band of heroes comes together to
destroy with van Helsing the vampires
forever
and then they totally blew it all right
I totally set the tone I'm perfectly
done but then they show you what they
just told you which is kind of weird cuz
like I would have told you really well
through text and then they give you a
let's look at five minutes seeing them
just like showing you what we just read
so they maybe get rid of one they're
both really enjoyable here's one thing
I'll say didn't love Dracula no I
thought you so underwhelming like you
think of Dracula says stoic just amazing
then you flash-forwards of these kids
and no thinking fifth sixth grade must
be and they are saying the most 80s
slurs for gay people oh yeah I'm to get
the f-word you get home oh god there's a
lot of making fun of fat guy it wasn't
appropriate instead of filling in Horace
they call him whore ass that really got
me my name is Horace I would own that I
was like oh that's me she's like haha
the pilots out of nowhere Dracula is for
some reason on a plane with
Frankenstein's body apparently right
which we learn later because the crate
actually says Frankenstein the pilots
like I'm depressed I hate flying these
planes there's no passengers we're going
nowhere it's just a bunch of boxes the
other guys like but you don't have to
give him peanuts he's like no you're
right a lot of yelling in this movie
about us like but unenthused yelling
what convinced yes oh great why don't we
get a vampire we get Frankenstein IV get
Wolfman and even his first moment of
appearing I was like wow that is
obviously a mask and he can totally turn
his head in it
realistic can't hit him and the swamp
monster has some super Batman like can't
turn their neck issues or it's like yes
but for the longest time we had no idea
where the mummy was he leaked randomly
show up in this kid's closet and then
left out a window so he literally had no
purpose in being that kid's closet
promptly disappeared yeah for a while
yeah until that moment until his demise
until interview and she's just fighting
in lots of closet like this squad comes
together but then you find out that it's
not really a squad know it's a hierarchy
but like that's within the monsters
right within the monsters it's a
hierarchy right apparently Dracula is
the master but like in our squad we're
all equal well whoa ask ask the leader
I wrote the kids get Van Helsing's diary
because of course of course they do and
they have to get it read by the
neighborhood's scary old German guy
because of course fright monsters are
after the diary because of course right
will they need it and then we find out
about an amulet because of course right
and right of course I mean it's an 80s
movie right and so all of this makes
complete sense I love that the sister
finds the monsters before the brothers
do yeah they're like where could these
monsters be and she's like hey guys
Children's Frankenstein who has no
reason at all to be good no sir I feels
like listen these kids got the diary you
have to get it and then kill them yeah
and Frankenstein's like yeah master got
it sure will I'm on that he sneaks up
behind the girl and I even was like oh
don't kill don't I'm like what his
behavior so they they might he's like
actually forget what my Master's say
I'll just be friendly she teaches him
the most 80s catchphrases yeah bogus is
great he also takes creepy photos of a
woman I wrote there's some super fun and
cool revenge porn very eighties very
yeah yeah no one say will you be the
Virgin and read this German for this
spell cuz of course it's in German right
um please and she's like no and they're
like okay well this nudie picture of you
says otherwise and she's like
damn okay I guess I would then you kind
of get annoyed with her because she's
not actually a virgin and she like it's
takes the entire world on right I'm like
saying that the hair first didn't count
girl the world is going to end dry your
tears suck it up and speak some German
German economy Narcy no I knew the nerd
scene was coming right because of NC
review right but they didn't disappoint
I think my favorite weapon in the entire
film is pizza although I do to really
love that Rudy
right cool guys Rudy made all these
weapons in shop class one day and then
the other kid is making a business card
I first was like what is that for but
they came back and it came back very
beautiful with a monster supply bitch
ones were calling people bitches show
colds before my girl and that calls her
a Big O so I was like whoa and then I
was like you know what that's a major
mood like I'm moved for 2018
ok right Jackie oh look it's look I
wonder if that was actually in the
script I'm gonna try something right if
it works it works
exactly just keep it they open up the
vortex of course and then van Helsing
comes back grabs Dracula in midair and
then gives everybody the thumbs up also
Frankenstein like loses his grip and
like a second to the vortex as well
right right and then it's just like
smiling and floating away goodbye
suppose maybe like a tear-jerking moment
but I was just like I was having too
much fun I cry okay my name Jack McGaw
it's Boris so it said basically if you
crossed Universal horror of The Goonies
and eighties cheese you get this film
yeah if you're not crying at the end
when Phoebe loses her grip on
Frankenstein and he says Phoebe goodbye
then you're the real monster here well
monsters
if the horns fit needs to be a gift
laughing oh oh oh I think the casual
sexism and racism will turn you off in
the movie it's something as a kid
watching it I didn't notice but I see it
as an adult yes and no it's one of those
things that you know it's coming because
it's it's like a kids action like
cheesefest from the 80s and yeah I don't
like obviously right obviously but I got
a new we cringed as the kids think
you're going to want to start your own
squad and hunt monsters and we're badass
leather jackets I mean only one of us
can though we have to all be tropes and
I think I missed one of us man yeah it
could be worse yeah it definitely did be
one time yeah thank you so much for
joining me
yeah thanks for having me amazing
adventure yeah to the monster squad the
monster hierarchy thank you so much for
watching everyone
I'll see you next week bad meeting
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you